now this directive is very limited but
it should expand this is the essential
Trump project he shatters these gooey
awful euphemisms and empty language
which is what political correctness is
to get to the heart of the matter in his
own very Trump ECOFIN a way watch him
expertly take on the euphemism army you
mean it's not politically correct and
yet everybody is is it I say you know
what give me a different term give me a
different term what else would you like
to say do you want me to say that okay
I'll use the word anchor baby excuse me
I'll use the word anchor baby it's
brilliant
this was by the way one of the moments
in the campaign where I started to think
that Donald Trump maybe wasn't just a
complete lunatic ignoramus so maybe he
knows what he's doing
because what he's saying there's an
anchor baby that's it paints a picture
we know what we meet we're talking about
children who were born in the United
States as a pathway to citizenship for
themselves and their families and it's
very hard to hear what that reporter is
saying but it's something to the effect
of well you should call them future
undocumented American citizens without
the blah blah blah blah blah securing
the whole thing and Trump says yeah you
know what I'm gonna stick with anchor
baby I'm gonna stick with the clear
language because that's how I'm going to
convince people about these issues I
can't convince them on your terms on
your crazy abuse of language I'm gonna
use reality you terms the better
correspond with reality and that's gonna
break your stranglehold on thought in
politics George Carlin the late comedian
talked about this himself here is we're
using that soft language that language
that takes the life out of life and it
is a function of time it does keep
getting worse get another example some
time during my life some time during my
lifetime paper became bathroom tissue
sneakers became running shoes false
teeth became dental appliances medicine
became medication information became
directory assistance
the dumped became the landfill car
crashes became automobile accidents
partly cloudy became partly sunny
motels became motor lodges house
trailers became mobile homes used cars
became previously owned transportation
room service became guest room dining
and constipation became occasional
irregularity by the way this is like
decades ago that he's talking about this
it's gotten so much worse since then but
it's that soft language it takes the
life out of the words it takes what's
convincing out of the words so that the
people who are using this deceptive
language they so that they can deceive
us euphemisms are insidious you know
people often say oh it's just semantics
your org you're just arguing over
semantics and of course these people
don't know what semantics means
semantics means meaning it's the study
of meaning it's how signs and words and
symbols relate to one another and to
reality this is why they're euphemisms
are so insidious they just proceed by
subtly deceiving us by painting it just
a little bit off an untrue picture of
reality at Christopher Hitchens wrote
for the sake of argument then one must
never let a euphemism or a false
consolation pass uncontested the truth
seldom lies but when it does lie it lies
somewhere in between
it lies it's oh it's just a little off
it's a little we're just gonna push you
slightly a little bit off the mark until
we see a vision of reality that bears no
relation to the truth Winston Churchill
mockingly admit it a quote perhaps we
have been guilty of some terminological
inexactitude 'he's he's really saying as
we lied we lied to you but he's mocking
even that at a continent concept in that
phrase terminological inexactitude have
you heard that if some lefty went on
television and said terminological
inexactitude Tjuta eyes would glaze over
and they would get away with the
deception but really it's lies that PC
and euphemisms like this are lies
language is the medium of our
consciousness it's how we view the world
that's why the left is so insistent on
political correctness on everybody using
their terms and looking at the world on
their terms this is why they're so
insistent over these pronouns virtually
nobody in the country suffers from
psychological gender confusion there are
like five of these people there are not
these people they're suffering and we
can be compassionate to them but the
left has invested countless funds
countless hours energy into a national
campaign to make everyone refer to men
as she and women as he we have why are
we talking about this all the time
doesn't that strike you as a little odd
if this campaign of language we're
really about the vanishingly small
minority of people clinically confused
about their biological sex wouldn't be a
smaller conversation but of course not
it's part of a larger project of
language to get us to buy their premises
their relativistic premises their
debased and barbaric view of politics
where we're just different competing
interest groups that have no relation to
the truth rather than civilized people
who look at the world in different ways
and debate it and try to get to reality
the truth is arrogant they try to use
reason to get to that truth here are
some other examples this is unbelievable
we no longer have criminals
according to Obama's Department of
Justice we have justice involved youth
justice involved youth is the
terminology that Obama's DOJ started
using to refer to criminal kids justice
and but now ironically their injustice
involved right they're committing
injustice as they're committing crime
but justice involved we can't even say
that they their offenders they're not
offenders they're just involved you know
I'm involved in justice right pay my
taxes so we have a criminal justice
system I give my legitimacy to a
government I admit to its credibility
that would be involved in justice these
kids are criminals but we have we can't
say that that's that's that's too mean
that gives us the wrong picture
we don't have Wars anymore we just have
overseas contingency operations whatever
it isn't it isn't that so a vivid
doesn't really paint a vivid picture the
government forcing you to buy a product
from a private company is not a mandate
it's not an unprecedented mandate it's a
quote individual shared responsibility
payment oh go okay in that case take my
money here's my check the estate tax is
used to refer to what is a death tax
what is the death tax when you die you
have to pay a tax
it's unbelievable what that has been
taxed at the corporate level at the
income level of the capital gains level
they but they've got to get you on the
estate rather on
the death tax by calling it the estate
tax oh well it's an estate it's no big
deal
illegal aliens became undocumented
workers the most absurd version of this
is the dreamers the dreamers these are
illegal aliens this is a clear term but
no they're just dreamers what do you do
you don't like the dreamers you hate
dream we want to kill dreams you monster
women's health now means killing a baby
in the womb that is women's health you
know and you you call up your
grandmother and you say are you doing
gee goes oh well I can still kill babies
in the womb so I have that at least I
have that I don't think so
but that is the euphemism we've even
gone past pro-choice which in itself is
ridiculous if of course it's a choice
the question is what choice is it we
have choices or free people the public
option or the single-payer system that
those are those two euphemisms instead
of government control health care we
have affirmative action instead of
racial discrimination but what is
affirmative action it's giving some
people privileges based on their race
and hurting some people based on their
race so I don't think that there's
anything terribly affirmative for Asian
students who are applying to American
universities what that is by their view
and by any serious view is racial
discrimination but that sounds too icky
mmm
terror attacks or man-caused disasters
get gay marriage was lost on these
grounds so the term gay marriage which
then became marriage equality even a
more outrageous euphemism it presumed a
premise so the conservative opposition
to gay marriage is not that gay people
should be discriminated against or not
have certain rights or whatever it's
that marriage does not include same-sex
unions it's just not what marriage is it
would be like it's just a nonsense it's
like saying what's the color of seven it
doesn't have a logical meaning but and
they left knew this so they used the
term the minute they use the term it
totally shifted the debate it skipped
the step of what is marriage what do we
think marriage is in 2017 in our culture
what does what does it mean for society
for individuals for the institution no
it became marriage can include same-sex
unions and will they have those rights
this is where we got to marriage
equality because if it's a question of
Rights and equality they have to win you
can't oppose right civil rights and
equality and it totally skipped over
totally dishonestly
and disingenuously skipped over the real
question which is what is marriage and
if we and if marriage can include
monogamous same-sex unions for the first
time ever why would we exclude
polygamous people or polyamorous
arrangements from marriage that is just
as bigoted by all of that logic
now there's raising revenue we always
have to raise revenue that's
confiscating well through taxation there
is a giveaway for the wealthy that means
allowing people to keep more of their
own money that's the giveaway for them
when you let them keep what's theirs
government spending has become
investment doesn't invest in anything
just spends but that's investment global
cooling became global warming which
became the unfold so file climate change
that's hard to beat that climate change
we noticed that it changes we noticed
that there are ups and downs so that's
how they they want an argument there
obviously obviously we have the holiday
that must not be named you know the
holiday you're getting ready for the
holiday season to welcome that big
holiday man with the big beard and and
really refer back to the incarnate birth
of the holiday guy yeah that's the the
this is what the war on Christmas is
about it's a same argument holds for the
war on Christmas who cares about the
words who cares just semantics right
they care there's a reason they care
even the word liberal became a liberal
we used to be liberals we're liberal now
they're not liberal they're completely
illiberal they're intolerant of anyone
elses views and we should take care to
follow presidents Trump true president
Trump's lead on this and avoid
euphemistic language at every turn I
know it's tempting I know I was just in
New York it's very tempting to try to
make the New York Times like us or
sophisticated fancy people like cocktail
parties like us just say who cares about
the pronouns who cares about these silly
terms it's just language they can have
it if they want it who cares the left
cares we should care to the left cares a
lot about it we should not cede to them
a syllable
because euphemistic language gives away
whole premises it in turn concedes the
culture ultimately it concedes our
politics and our government and our
Liberty words matter ideas matter reject
PC gobbledygook and only use the best
words folks come on we have them we got
the best words